hello everyone and welcome to a most
awaited match from the final round of
the 37th European Club cup it is
vishwanathan Ananda versus Arjun
eriggaisi uh you've been hearing a lot
about Arjun and gulkish and they've been
just storming the world stop rating
lists uh both of them 2700 plus 2720
plus reaching almost 27 30 plus so that
is uh quite uh quite spectacular but uh
one person holds the uh the title of the
highest rank player from India and that
of course is a former world champion
vishwanathan Anand who's still at the
age of 52 is amongst the world's top 10
so an incredible feat in itself and now
Arjun will get a chance with the black
beast system grab a few points from
Anand so let's see how the game went you
will really have to focus for this one
because it's really hard to follow so
Anand with the white pieces opens with
Ponte E4 we have Ponte E5 Knight to F3
Knight the C6 and Bishop to B5 so on and
challenges too to a nice classical rui
Lopez and there are many possible
replies here you could go for the morphe
defense with A6 you could play the
Berlin with Knight to F6 you could play
f5d yeah again but you could play Bishop
to C5 the the classical defense against
the real Lopez you could play D6 the old
shiniest defense uh but um Arjun goes
for the sixth most popular option and
that is the kozio defense with Knight
G37 and this is where he will uh test uh
anan's Theory so Anand replies with
Knight to C3 just continuing development
Knight to G6 now even if the Knight is
captured the E5 Pawn is defended and
Anand strikes in the center with Pawn to
D4 and now e Captain D4 is sort of the
move here but Arjun plays Knight
captures on D4 so he really prepared
something special for Anand Knight
captures e captures and after Queen
capture Sunday for just C6 chasing away
the bishop Bishop to C4 and now even
upon the B5 chasing the bishop away
further back now you could play Bishop
B3 you could play Bishop B2
Bishop D2 by Arjun and now there is a
game from the uh from this year actually
between kiroshofchenko and the
Christopher lepka where Bishop Queen to
B6 was played the game ended in a draw
but here we have Ponta B4 Arjun not
messing around he goes for anan's Knight
and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how Anan deals with it so of course he
can go back to B1 he can go back to D1
but he plays Knight the A4 which seems a
bit scary but he has a very very a nice
idea of what he wants to do of course
now he controls the C5 square at some
point the bishop will come to E3 so he
will further gain and more control and
after Bishop to E7 and C4 uh this is
where it really gets interesting now if
Arjun captures would be capture C just
brings the Knight back into the game so
of course that's not gonna happen but
it's very interesting what Anand had in
mind if Arjun went Queen to A5 now the
Knight is hanging and also B3 a
discovered check is coming well here you
would have the plane Queen to D1
interestingly B3 of course doesn't work
Bishop to F6 and well this is much
better for black so Queen to D1 would
have to be played and now you really
don't have much to worry about if B3
check you just play Bishop to D2 and you
are very happy even if Queen to E5 you
can even give up D for Pawn for example
castles Queen characters and E4 and
rookie one and the black is in uh well
black will have difficulties in this
position so that's why not Queen to A5
even though uh the it's perfectly fine
to play the engine really likes this
move but uh castles is what Arjun goes
for we have Castles by Anand and now
Bishop to F6 the bishop now assumes this
diagonal attacks the queen queen to D3
you have to free up this diagonal for
the bishop so uh might as well uh play
it there Rook the E8 and now Pawn to C5
and under gaining a nice control here a
D5 is no longer possible because just C
characters and D6 Upper song and uh well
it's it's not possible so Queen to E7
Ponta F3 now and then saying okay show
me show me what I have to be worried
about uh while playing this line I'm
just enjoying my position very much for
the moment and Bishop to E5 now Arjun
shows that he will be able to play D5 as
now D6 is covered by both the bishop and
the Queen and also he might have some
very unpleasant ideas towards anan's
King so Anan just plays G3 which gives
him more more protection the king is now
a bit safer but it also gives a target
for Arjun to hone in on he will play H5
H4 and try to open up anand's King side
so here
uh D5 striking in the center now you
have to play C captures on D6 of course
this is a mandatory Bishop captures and
now Rook to D1 the The Rook no longer
serves a purpose and the f file so it is
shifted to D1 with Tempo now the bishop
is hanging Bishop back to C6 and now
Bishop to E3 of course you don't want to
allow this bishop to ever come to this
diagonal so now with full control over
the C5 Square uh Anand is very happy and
notice that Arjun already pushed the B
Pawn into the d-pawn so once this Knight
lands and C5 is going to be very hard to
get rid of it from there so here Arjun
starts the attack on the king's side
plays H5 Knight to C5 it's not yet a
monster Knight but it's it's a really
fancy Knight so Knights the E5 attacking
the queen queen to C2 and now Pawn to H4
continuing the attack and Anand now has
to figure out how to deal with this you
could play something like King to G2 and
play spawn to F4 and now just Knight the
G4 and although you could trade here it
doesn't look like something you want to
do you just develop Origins Bishop for
free allow his his Rooks to connect and
well not not how you want to play chess
so after this we have Bishop to D4
as the bishop on E3 was a Target and
here you nicely control arjun's Knight
and G4 and also put put some pressure on
Black's King side so Rook to d8 and now
we have Knight back to A4 Bion and here
we have to be really careful like the
king uh the the king feels okay on G2
but here uh you might run into some
ideas like Rook captures on D4 and now
you will have to play Bishop characters
on on G4 because if Rook captures then
Knight to the E3 check just picks up the
queen and C2 so Anand has to be careful
here he goes Knight back to A4 and now
what do you play here it's a very very
tricky position and well a sacrifice is
needed here if you wanna uh break
through white wise defenses uh and the
sacrifice that I'm talking about is
eight captures on G3 H captures in now
just Bishop captures and F4 that's how
we want to break through G captures Rook
D6 and go after the G file this is not
winning for black or anything this is
still perfectly fine for white but it is
the best Arjun can get out of the
position instead of this he goes for the
immediate sacrifice with Knight captures
on H2 and this will be a bit more
difficult to attack than the previous
position that we've shown so King
captures Anand has to accept the
sacrifice H captures on G3 and not King
G2 of course not capturing the G3 Pawn
because then Queen G5 check and
everything just falls apart you will not
be able to defend this uh if you want to
we can even show like Queen F2 Queen H4
check King to G2 Bishop captures an F4
going for G3 going for H2 you you cannot
survive this so after age captures and
G3 King to G2 which is very important as
now you have a rook to H1 whenever you
need it so you don't have to worry about
Queen H4 Queen H2 and here we have
Bishop captures and F4 yeah
interestingly it's the best move
by the engine and Arjun really uh uh you
know you know they're playing this
attack well but there is a move that
completely stops the attack and gives
Anand a winning position but it's not an
easy move to find so feel free to pause
the video and try to win this game for
Anand um while I give you a couple of
seconds and I will give you a little
hint uh think of anan's immortal game
against Levon aronian uh that was played
in 2015 in the Tata steel might give you
a nice nice idea
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing what I
was talking about but even if you didn't
know the game or you haven't seen it
congratulations on solving the position
as the movie's Bishop to C5 yeah I don't
played this in the game against tarunian
only he had the black pieces in that
game if you still haven't seen it do
check it out it's I mean it's such a
beautiful game I will put a link to it
in the description it will be the first
thing you see so you know you can check
it out after the game if you want but
yeah now uh Arjun has a very unpleasant
decision what to do the queen is hanging
you can't just move the queen anywhere
you have to keep defending your Rook
here and there are a couple of options
to explore like uh maybe bishop D6 maybe
you don't want to trade you can offer a
trade of Bishops but now Anan just plays
Rook to H1 and there's just no good way
to to get the attack now you you guard
the H2 Square the other Rook is coming
Def One you will guard the F2 square if
Bishop captures Knight captures the
Knight here is a spectacular piece
completely nullifying the bishop
and well you're on the attack you you
have to be developed and you here you
are severely underdeveloped so instead
after Bishop to C5 you could play Queen
F6 it might also be a nice idea but
Anand would just trade captures captures
and now play even Bishop captures on B4
this would be just a slap in the face
grabbing a pawn in a position like this
the problem is you don't have anything
if Queen H4 Rook H1 if you try something
like Queen D4 to go Rook to go Queen F2
then just Rook F1 you guard the F2
square there's no way to reach the the
white king and even if Queen before
attacking the bishop you still don't
care because Rook F1 you guard F2 and
you're attacking uh the the bishop and
F4 and if captures captures the Knight
is defended and if Queen D6 attacking
The Rook you can just play Rook F3 if
Bishop G4 attacking The Rook even The
Rook D3 you you still don't have to rush
with capturing and G3 you attack the
queen and the ones Queen H6 is played
going after this check sort of trying to
give up the bishop I would just play
real characters on G3 and there's not
much to do Bishop characters Queen
characters and yes the white king is
wide open but the problem is after a
move like Rook d8 let's say you want to
go Rook D2 can play Rook D3 and if Rook
if E8 going for E4 now just Knight goes
back into the game with C3 the Knight
can never be opposed there's no B Pawn
there's no d-pawn uh the E4 Pawn is
protected uh you're just up a piece so
of course you will win
so because of all that after Bishop to
C5 we have a most unexpected decision by
Arjun and that is to give up the queen
Arjun plays Rook captures on D1 now he
leaves the queen hanging and Anand has
to accept it I mean there there is no
better move so he captures the queen and
Arjun grabs the other Rook as well so
two Rooks for a queen it's not a bad
deal only Arjun already sacrificed the
piece so it's
um not quite so here uh it's again you
have to be very very careful but Queen
captures on C6 is sufficient it attacks
the rook and also threatens Queen to E8
check but Arjun thought of this as well
and it seems like you could play Rook
the B8 and it is such a spectacular line
that I will show it I apologize before
making the video I said that we will
cover a few more lines in this game
because they are spectacular but just to
see what they had to analyze because
Anand burned almost all of his time
calculating the positions in this game
he ended the game like maybe with four
minutes and the clock so here Queen the
E8 check King the H7 and queen captures
on F7 now putting pressure on the bishop
now there is a bishop to H3 check and
this is also something that you have to
calculate King captures on H3 Rook the
H1 with check and now the very
unpleasant Choice King G2 or King to G4
King G2 and you can no longer win this
with white because uh we just harass the
white king Rook HD checking a three Rook
def to checking G4 and now G2 and the G1
is coming even if Queen to F5 check King
to H and queen to H5 with check uh you
can block with Bishop to H6 and again
not a lot to do you can play Queen H2
this guards the G1 square and the tags
The Rook here and just Rook the E8
attacks the bishop and now let's say
Bishop F3 you have to give up some
material Rook captures on E7 now came to
G3 you chase away the rook and after
Rook the D2 now you can capture here and
uh you've you've eliminated the pawn
here but you will not be winning this
game it's just too hard to coordinate
white pieces however after Rook H1 check
King G4 is a possibility and now Anand
would just be straight out winning
because after G2 uh there's again the
saving Bishop the C5 which is kind of
the theme of this game uh stopping this
um uh G1 idea and also the bishop is
hanging so there's really not all that
much to do here
so that's that's the problem of why Rook
the ba doesn't work so Arjun finds Rook
to E1 another way to ask some questions
and now Anand has to decide what to do
Anand plays Bishop to C4 and this is
again very important if you just grab
the Rook then Rook captures an E2 and
you're pretty much in the in the same uh
boat that's not really you know going
well Rook C2 and now Bishop C5 yes you
are guarding this diagonal uh against
the past Pawn but now King H7 unpinning
now the bishop can be activated and if
Queen captures special which is kind of
your only thing G2 checking G1 and now
you force Bishop to E3 check uh and now
the bishop must be captured if the king
moves you promote the pawn uh with check
bringing your queen into the game and if
Bishop captures you win back your queen
and now it's rook and four rook and okay
King cap or some G2 so look in Four
Points versus uh Bishop Knight and three
pawns should be a draw so that's why uh
you can't capture the queen right away
so instead we have bush up to C4 now you
don't have to worry about this piece
hanging here and Rook the C1 now pinning
the bishop and now comes King to F3
putting pressure on the bishop on F4
King the H7 and now Anand again has to
make a choice this was the final attempt
at um mixing mix again up for example if
King captures on F4 then G2 is very very
strong and Anand will not be winning
this game but Anand said now is the time
to capture The Rook Queen capture 78 was
played Ponte G2 and now Bishop to C5
uh interestingly uh King characters on
CT also works but uh yeah Bishop the C5
just takes care of all of the tactics
and you don't even have to calculate now
root captures on C4 was played Queen
characters and C8 was played and now G1
Queen happened in the game uh hoping for
of course Bishop captures on uh G1 and
then Rook captures on C8 which would
just be a draw but here Anand plays the
absolute strongest and the only winning
move Queen to H3 with check so he just
gets the queen out of her Queen out of
Harm's Way and he was in this position
on move 35 that Arjun Erica resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here once the king moves or you block
with Bishop to H4 just bishop cappers
and G1 wins the second Queen and that's
it now you're just down too much
material to even uh consider playing
this
uh so yeah brilliant game by by both of
them uh we uh Anand played the played a
little bit better and he was able to
take down Arjun who really tried tried a
lot first with with this uh well like I
said sixth most popular continuation
then finding this uh very very
unpleasant continuation of the immediate
B4 uh and I mean it's just uh crazy
crazy position uh opening up the center
and attacking on the king side and it
was all well up until this point where
uh just captures captures and Bishop
captures on F4 and it's still a game I
mean you play it but uh uh it's it's
gonna be uh much harder to defend even
though white is still perfectly fine
might even be better but this was the
way to go he he chose a different
sacrifice the wrong one and then Anan
just exploited it brilliantly uh after
finding this bishop to C5 move which
which pretty much seals the deal uh so
yeah great attack great defense a great
counter attack great game hope you guys
enjoyed it I had a great time showing it
and let's not forget what this means for
the standings as where are my standings
uh should be somewhere around here uh as
of course both of them uh are are very
top on the on the world the rating list
so this is the world rating list now
regarding classical play and the live
one of course not the not the static one
so as you can see okay Magnus still on
2858 with plus 2.2.8 as he had a very
good event but Anand okay he dropped two
points because he lost that game to Hari
Krishna but still he returns the number
nine in the world uh and Arjun drops the
number 25 number to win 23 and you can
see vidit who had six wins in a row is
up by 19 points so he's plus 19 he's on
a number 19 in the world currently so
that's what's happening karwana plus 6.4
also very nice goes up three squares to
number five uh that's what's happening
in the top of the classical Chess World
that's right once again that's the game
and a little bit of additional info hope
you guys enjoyed that I would like to
thank GJ red rose Kerrigan uh David
David and Matthew Benoit for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and if you still
haven't seen anand's Immortal game uh
first link in the description below see
you soon